the Republican primary field is very
quickly getting much more crowded
including with two very interesting new
entrants Mike Pence expected to announce
he will run against his own former
president under whom he served and Chris
Christie is going to announce that he is
entering this race which is very very
interesting for other reasons which I
will talk about in a moment we will
start with Mike Pence Mike Pence reports
NPR expected to announce 2024 run for
president on on June 7th at an event in
Des Moines according to a source
familiar with the campaign I am sure
that it will be an electric atmosphere
when Mike Pence makes this announcement
no it won't uh it will be quite the
opposite but it will be an interesting
announcement nonetheless and we'll talk
about why in a moment NPR writes Pence
has been signaling his plans for several
months with several stops in early
voting States like New Hampshire and
Iowa
and the announcement of a Super PAC
supporting his bid Pence will join at
least nine other Republicans attempting
to unseat Trump as the front-runner for
the Republican nomination now what will
Pence's campaign look like because if
you serve as vice president to Trump and
then you run against him you can't do
the thing that Nikki Haley and Tim Scott
and others are doing where you don't
criticize Trump right if you're saying I
disagree so much with the guy I served
under that I will run against him you
have to explain what your disagreements
are I think NPR writes in the past
several weeks Pence has previewed a
campaign focused on returning the
Republican party to traditional
Republican themes like expanding free
markets fiscal responsibilities
supporting American Allies abroad and
small government he has made more
pointed attacks on Trump his former
running mate by invoking his own Faith
and family values and promising to
respect to respect the Constitution here
is an MSNBC NBC news report of the
moment when news of this broke
[Music]
we have breaking news regarding a new
entry into the already crowded
Republican race for President we told
you last hour that on Tuesday Chris
Christie was getting in now on Wednesday
former vice president Mike Pence NBC's
John Allen has the very latest he's
breaking the story and joins me on the
phone John what can you tell us
uh I can tell you Mike Pence is in uh as
of a week from today he will be doing a
video uh probably in the morning and
then a launch speech in Des Moines Iowa
it is very focused on uh Iowa as are a
lot of campaigns as a place that they
believe is very hospitable to the former
Vice President part because of its uh
strong Evangelical Republican base so
he'll be doing that speech uh sometime
on uh on the seventh and then uh there's
going to be a town hall later that night
okay so that is the CNN Town Hall last
week we we thought that Pence was going
in this direction because we knew CNN
had scheduled a republican town hall
with Pence and we said to ourselves
would they be doing that if this guy was
not going in the direction of running so
currently currently Mike Pence is
running in fourth place we have the
latest polling here as you can see the
big purple line at the top is Trump at
53 the green line sort of in the middle
of this screen is DeSantis at 22 so
Trump 53 DeSantis 22 then it's Nikki
Haley at about four and a half percent
and after Nikki Haley is Mike Pence at
3.8 percent just ahead of Vivek
ramaswamy will the announcement get some
new support for Mike Pence it might a
couple of points worth I would I would
expect but is this going to be a big
shake-up to the Republican primary I
don't think so and part of it has to do
with the fact that many of the very
people
who are not on the Maga side
don't see Penn says the strongest
alternative partially because Pence even
though he may be displeased with some of
the way that Donald Trump managed the
presidency or whatever Pence is too
close if you want to go anti-maga you
probably don't go with the Maga vice
president as much distance as Pence
would like to put between himself and
Trump so the question is going to be
for the Maga group
is there an alternative to Trump I doubt
it would be Pence because many of those
Maga people are mad that Pence quote
didn't send it back to the states in uh
in in 2020
um to try to prevent Joe Biden from
becoming president in 2020 and 2021 even
though he really couldn't do that and so
it's unlikely that they would say well
we really are Maga we want something
better so we'll go with Pence because
they see Pence as an enemy quite frankly
thanks to the rhetoric from Donald Trump
on the other hand the anti-maga people
would likely go with someone who was
never affiliated with Donald Trump so I
don't exactly see how Mike Pence is
going to get anything out of this Mike
Pence is I believe in his early in his
early 60s 60s Mike Pence age a 63 so I
don't know if Pence is calculating that
if he wants to do this he'd rather do it
at age 63 rather than 67 and maybe
closer to when he is more of a household
name maybe fit Thinking by 2028 maybe
people will have forgotten about me I
don't know again I don't exactly know
what Pence is thinking I see the
campaign is Dead on Arrival but let's
now talk about a much more interesting
campaign than that of Mike Pence let's
talk about Chris Christie former New
Jersey Governor Chris Christie former
Trump endorser Chris Christie is going
to be running against Donald Trump and
the other Republicans in the primary
field for the Republican Presidential
nomination NBC News is now reporting
former New Jersey Governor Chris
Christie to announce his 2024
presidential bid on Tuesday it is
Christie's second run for the nomination
he will announce at a town hall in
Manchester New Hampshire to sources were
confirmed the article reminds us that
Chris Christie stumbled is the word they
used to a sixth place finish in 2016's
New Hampshire primary axios was the
first to report the timing of Christie's
announcement after he dropped out of the
race eight years ago Christie endorsed
Trump days before super Tuesday lending
a credible name to Trump's momentum uh
another interesting aspect to this is
that ABC News is immediately suspending
its relationship with Chris Christie
Chris Christie has been a analyst
contributor sort of person on ABC
ABC has announced that at least for now
they are suspending their relationship
with Chris Christie because he is indeed
becoming an official candidate so I'm
going to be very transparent with
everybody here if you came to Me Maybe
with tears in your eyes and said David
if you knew that one of the Republicans
currently running would be the next
president of the United States who would
you pick I pick Chris Christie and when
you say to me okay well there's Trump
there's DeSantis Nikki Haley Tim Scott
Mike Pence Vivek ramaswamy at this point
I don't even remember who else is
running you've got
um I guess ASA Hutchinson God forbid uh
no listen I mean from this group I go
with Chris Christie Chris Christie as a
New Jersey governor a blue state that
sometimes elects Republican governors in
the mode of what we've seen happen in
Massachusetts as well over the years
William weld Mitt Romney
um I I can't believe I'm blanking a
Charlie Baker more recently uh
I would I would be if you said forget
about Democrats it's just it's going to
be one of these Republicans I think I go
with Christy I actually think Christy is
more intelligent than a lot of the other
people he's running against I will
remind folks that this could be a factor
if Christy gets on the debate stage with
Trump
um Christy is actually pretty good in
debates and remember these moments back
from 2016 when Christy really made Marco
Rubio look stupid by pointing out that
Rubio is in a sort of talking point coma
repeating the same thing over and over
and over again remember this classic
moment you have not been involved in a
consequential decision where you had to
be held accountable you just simply
haven't say I want the people at home to
think about this that's what Washington
DC does the drive-by shot at the
beginning with Incorrect and incomplete
information and then the memorized 25
second speech that is exactly what
[Applause]
see
see Marco
when you're president United States when
you're a governor of a state the
memorized 30-second speech where you
talk about how great America is at the
end of it doesn't solve one problem for
one person this notion that Barack Obama
doesn't know what he's doing is just not
there it is
memorize 25 seconds
you know what the shame is you know what
the shame is Marco the shame is that you
would actually criticize somebody for
showing up to work plowing the streets
getting the trains run back on time when
you've never been responsible for that
in your entire life all right so listen
Chris Christie can debate I would be
from an entertainment standpoint I would
be very interested in seeing the
approach that Christy would take to
Trump from a pragmatic standpoint if I
had to pick from this group of
Republicans who is the next president it
would be Chris Christie and I think
probably by a long shot uh it is I think
maybe interesting or important to note
there are Maga people already making fun
of Chris Christie for being obese
Trump's obese it's stunning to me that
the supporters of one obese candidate
are making fun of another candidate for
also being obese I mean yes Christy
seems more obese than Trump I I saw some
tweets going around about uh uh Chris
Christie doesn't need to run for
president he just needs to run like go
out and jog in order to lose weight if
that's the best that the Maga people can
come up with against Christy I actually
am very interested to see whether Chris
Christie can get some traction because
he is quick he's got a quicker wit he's
smarter he has experience as a
prosecutor a sort of experience that is
uh lacking and in the Republican primary
and might actually be interesting if
confronted with Trump on a debate stage
so I'm going to be following the Chris
Christie candidacy interesting uh
closely and and from an interested
perspective if it's Christy versus Biden
I'm voting for Biden certainly I agree
with Biden much more on policy
but I think that that's the most
interesting you know Vivek ramaswamy so
boring Tim Scott Dead on Arrival who
cares Pence oh my goodness Pence might
try to bore the audience into submission
uh but Chris Christie I find a little
bit interesting let me know your
thoughts make sure you're subscribed on
YouTube at youtube.com the David Pacman
show we'll take a quick break and be
right back
don't forget that the best way to
support the David Pacman show is by
becoming a member which gives you access
to the Daily bonus show The Regular Show
with no commercials you also get access
to our entire Archive of every episode
dating back a really long time and
plenty of other awesome membership perks
go to joinpakman.com joinpakman.com
legal experts are once again talking
about the possibility of the failed
former president Donald Trump being
charged federally under the Espionage
Act because of an audio recording that
has now been obtained that is insanely
damaging to Trump let me give you the
lowdown CNN Trump captured on tape
talking about classified document he
kept after leaving the White House the
details here are critical Federal
prosecutors have an audio recording from
a meeting in summer of 2021 remember
this is after Trump left the White House
in which former president Trump
acknowledges he held on to a classified
Pentagon document about a potential
attack on Iran multiple sources told CNN
undercutting his argument that he
Declassified everything remember Trump
said I Declassified everything I took
but in this audio recording Trump
actually says this is classified I can't
show it to you therefore he did not
declassify it the recording indicates
Trump understood that he retained
classified material after leaving the
White House on the recording Trump's
comments suggests he would like to share
the information but he's aware of
limitations on his ability
post-presidency to declassify records
two of the sources said if Trump knows I
have something here that has not been
Declassified that is because he didn't
declassify it directly counter to his
claim that he Declassified everything
special counsel Jack Smith who's leading
the Justice Department investigation has
focused on the meeting as part of the
criminal investigation into Trump's
handling of National Security Secrets
sources described the recording as an
important piece of evidence in a
possible case against Trump trump
um prosecutors have asked Witnesses
about the recording and the document
before a Federal grand jury the episode
has generated enough interest for
investigators to question General Mark
milley about the incident the July 2021
meeting was held at Trump's Golf Club in
Bedminster with two people working on
the autobiography of Trump's former
Chief of Staff Mark Meadows as well as
aides employed by Trump including
communication specialist Margot Martin
the attendees did not have security
clearances that would allow them access
to classified information Meadows wasn't
at the meeting
Meadows autobiography includes an
account of what happened at the meeting
during which Trump recalls a four-page
report type typed up by Mark milley
himself containing the General's plan to
attack Iran deploying massive numbers of
troops something he urged Trump to do
more than once during his presidency the
document Trump references was not
produced by Millie this is absolutely
stunning in a number of different ways
there's another article from Business
Insider reports of bombshell Trump
recording suggests prosecutors may have
grounds to charge Trump under the
Espionage Act there are a number of
important issues here number one if the
audio recording is as described Trump is
admitting that he has unauthorized
possession of a document relating to
National Defense Trump's original claim
was I Declassified everything on the way
out either de facto or through some kind
of telepathy or right it didn't make
sense but Trump's claim was I
Declassified all of it but then Trump is
saying in this meeting when Joe Biden is
already president Trump's out of the
White House
he's saying I have something here that
is uh classified so I can't show it to
you this shows Trump knew it was a lie
to say I Declassified everything
secondly the meeting took place in
Bedminster this was not the location of
the search warrant that was served you
will remember the search warrant was
served at Mar-A-Lago and we said at the
time if there are documents at
Mar-A-Lago that Trump isn't supposed to
have there are almost certainly
documents at Bedminster Michael Cohen
Trump's former lawyer said there are
almost certainly documents at Bedminster
and now we have a a recording that took
place at Bedminster where Trump is there
and he has a document that he says is
classified a document he doesn't
actually have the right to just take
with him so we now are expanding the
circle of criminality involving multiple
Trump homes or golf clubs or whatever
you want to call them and then in
addition there are people on the
recording who don't actually have the
security clearance anyway and would
probably be pretty desperate and pretty
incentivized to keep themselves out of
jail
uh and so they could actually become
Witnesses against Donald Trump here this
is an immense story and we are now going
to listen to an interview with one of
Trump's lawyers who's increasingly a TV
lawyer where he seems to be really
struggling to explain this all right so
let's go to some CNN video CNN
interviewed Trump lawyer Jim trustee
about the leaked audio recording in
which Trump is at Bedminster Golf Club
not at Mar-A-Lago it's summer of 2021
long after Trump has left the White
House and Biden as president and Trump
on the auto audio recording says I have
a classified document here that I can't
show you proving that Trump did not
declassify all of the documents that he
took with him meaning he took classified
documents to which he did not have uh
the right
then we go to CNN last night here's
Caitlin Collins asking Trump's lawyer if
the documents were Declassified As Trump
told us they were why is Trump on the
recording saying I can't show you this
because it's classified very
straightforward and simple question Jim
trusty unable to answer
ask about something you just said to
Abby which was you referenced the fact
that Trump was still president when he
left office he left Washington I think
he about an hour left in his presidency
are you saying that it was in that hour
that he Declassified the documents that
were taken with him now your timing is a
little bit off that he's he landed in
Mar-A-Lago and was at his residence
while still president it was a little
bit after that that Biden was sworn in
so he he had the absolute authority to
take every one of those documents any
document he wants with him when he left
the White House what happens throughout
history through Modern History okay now
he's already he's already being
deceptive
in some hypothetical sense if Trump goes
through the declassification process
while President he would then be able to
make the case that he can take documents
he didn't do that things are not de
facto Declassified because Trump thought
about it or because Trump took them and
Trump admits on the recording that these
are still classified documents meaning
he did not declassify them this guy's
lying and he's being deceptive but if
you take documents and archives thinks
they're entitled to it they start
negotiating and that's what he did he
was telling them things like hey just
ask if you want anything more he gave
them 15 boxes in January of 2022. after
some back back and forth but just to be
clear you're making the argument right
now by the time he was on the ground in
Florida after he left Washington that
that is when he Declassified all of
these documents that he took with him no
no I'm saying the documents he brought
with him are effectively
Declassified effectively is doing some
heavy lifting in this sentence and the
problem is lawyers not working for Trump
say that that's not a thing and
personalized under the presidential
record act we're talking about
constitutional Authority Under the
Constitution to declassify if he wants
to take stuff with him and say anything
I take with me is Declassified if he
wants to take stuff and say anything I
read at night is Declassified that was
absolutely his right as president even
if that were the case he didn't do it
and admits the document is classified in
the summer of 2021. and the personal the
presidential records act makes it clear
that we don't even care about classified
information it is a statutory scheme but
if this deals with presidential or
personal only Jim if this was
Declassified then why are we told that
he's on this tape basically telling the
people in the room that he can't share
it with them you are told by doj or FBI
or whoever filtered that to you anything
they can think of to justify all right
so it's all unfair it's all a Witch Hunt
to justify uh indicting Trump here's one
more clip
um uh here's Abby Philip interviewing uh
the same guy Jim trustee and uh it
doesn't really go any better these tapes
would indicate that former president
Trump knew that the documents that he
had were classified yes does that not
make uh his statements about blanket
declassification and some statements by
his Representatives wouldn't that make
those lies yeah I'm not going to dignify
the doj leak what I will tell you is
this when you are because it's extremely
inconvenient to my client
you don't want to address the substance
well it'd also be nice if you let me
answer so let me just try to answer
because he's not actually trying to
answer that's the thing I am trying to
be responsive but I'm not going to bite
on a leak campaign and try the case in
the media what I will tell you is there
is no doubt that as commander-in-chief
and when the president left Washington
DC from Orlando he was actually still
president when he left for Mar-A-Lago
with boxes of documents that other
people packed for him that he brought at
least now he's admitting there were
boxes huh he was the commander-in-chief
there is no doubt that he has the
Constitutional Authority as
commander-in-chief to declassify it does
not have to go through some sort of
bureaucratic process to be Declassified
but wouldn't it be very easy to Simply
prove that he just Declassified them
because even though he doesn't have to
go through a process right he does have
to decide that it's been done did he
tell anyone yes and and can you prove it
sure but we're not doing it did he
declassify this document that we're
referring to we're not going to try that
all right so as you can see this is a
very poor appearance for Jim trustee one
lawyer wrote to me and said you know
these might be TV lawyer arguments David
to avoid answering the question into
obfuscate these are not arguments any
sensible lawyer would ever make in court
so Trump's going to need something
better than Jim trusts these arguments
if he hopes to to to uh somehow explain
this recording if this actually is
something that leads to charges so again
Espionage being discussed as a possible
situation for Trump we're going to
follow it super closely
if you value what we do at the David
packman show remember to support us on
patreon go to patreon.com davidpackman
show where you can get access to behind
the scenes videos The Daily bonus show
the commercial free Daily Show as well
as special discounts on merch including
hats hoodies mugs and t-shirts you can
support the show for as little as two
dollars a month check it out at
patreon.com davidpackman show today we
are welcoming author Robert Greene to
the program who's written seven
International bestsellers including the
48 Laws of Power The Art of Seduction
the laws of human nature and others most
of which I've read Robert really
appreciate your time today
thanks for having me David my pleasure
so one of the things maybe we could
start with is I've read a little bit
about your process when you write a book
and the wealth of material that you will
read and then how you will sort of
catalog and have a repository of the
things you've read in preparation for
the books that you write one of the
things that I struggle with personally
and I know many in our audience do also
is
how to have a system to determine what
is worth reading studying or paying
attention to today and of course with
social media and endless streaming
content and sports and history and
economics and all of the different
things that people could spend time
reading and learning about what's your
process for even at the top level
determining what is worthy of our
attention in 2023
well I'm very aware of the dangers of of
trying to digest too much information
overloading the brain
so when I write a book I try and make it
as focused and concentrated as possible
excuse me I cut out as many distractions
as as humanly possible
and um so in the beginning I choose a
subject that can be rather wide-ranging
like power
or my fifth book Mastery and
um and then I read I try and find all of
the books that deal with that subject
that I think are going to be direct and
realistic and practical my method is I'm
trying to really change the way you look
at the world change the way you think
from the inside out and the only way to
do that is to actually have a really
solid basis in research in reality so I
can make the book as practical as
possible
so I sort of start by casting a wide net
and I read all the great books out there
on excuse me
for instance on power
and then slowly I start narrowing it
down to things that are a little bit
more specific and it's kind of a fun
process so if I just kept it too narrow
and I just focused on very small little
width of of books about power it
wouldn't be fun for me part of the
excitement because if I'm excited I
think the book tends to have to be
exciting to the reader part of the
excitement is finding things that I
never expected to find so I go from one
book and then I look at the bibliography
it references another book it excites me
on and on and on by the end of the
process I've read two three hundred
books to be able to write one book and
so
um I'm you know I'm reading an awful lot
but I have to kind of organize the
material and where a lot of books I
think fail
is they they don't they're not organized
well so I've created a system with cards
where I put I read a book and then I put
all of the material on it on cards and I
organize it by subject by category and
then I could show you if I ever if I if
you ever wanted my system of cars I have
thousands of cards for one book so I try
and keep my attention very focused on
the things that are incredibly important
and practical to give my book a kind of
this grounding in reality and then I
organize the material in a very almost
fetishistic way so that I can make it so
that the reader doesn't feel like I'm
overloading them with information even
though I myself have consumed vast
amounts of literature on the subject
do you have any overarching approach to
as a consumer of media in which I would
include books and all of the other forms
of media that are out there if people in
our audience have it their disposal
books of all sorts of different genres
as well as audio visual content music
all of the different things playing
Video Games Etc what is an approach to
figuring out what is quote worth
spending time on versus not worth it
which certainly would vary from person
to person is it objective based in terms
of what it is you are looking to achieve
over a period of time and which forms of
information consumption will get you
closer or how should the average person
think about this for you know reading
your books versus novels watching sports
reading narrative nonfiction about Teddy
Roosevelt or whatever maybe what is
there an approach that you could suggest
well it depends on on the individual and
so um one thing that I think is really
important is that you have a very firm
understanding of who you are and what
your life is about and your objectives
in life and what makes you different
from other people so so many people
don't have that deep connection to what
to what to what their um vocation is in
life they're calling and so they'll read
anything because they don't have a
filter so I think it's very very
important and I talk a lot about this in
my book Mastery that you have a very
very firm sense of this is where I want
to go in like this is what connects to
me this is what excites me so without
that kind of filter without that kind of
focus then you're kind of lost at sea
and you're reading all kinds of things
that aren't going to help you in the end
I mean at some point
I myself like to waste time you know
like anybody else so I will get on and
I'll look at YouTube videos or podcasts
or read material that isn't directly
related to my work and I think it's
important to sometimes relax and not be
so rigid about this but I think you have
to have a sense of where you of who you
are what you like what's important to
you what matters what where your career
is going and then from there you
determine what's important for you to
read because the problem we're facing
today quite frankly is we're just
inundated with too much information with
trivia that just clogs the brain up it
makes it very very hard for you to focus
makes it very hard for you to actually
think about your own priorities in life
so you can't
find an app or some teacher that's going
to help you do that it has to come from
within you have to have a sense of who
you are what makes you different what's
important to you what your values are
and from there you can then filter out
the information that's completely
useless or that's more important for you
do you think that at this point in time
it is still the case that there might be
some Core Curriculum of sorts the idea
of some kind of you know at one point it
was the classical education where there
were certain works that no matter what
your vocation or interests were maybe
worthy or almost like a required reading
of sorts does that idea still ring in
any way true to you today or has sort of
human life on Earth in 2023 becomes so
diverse that that very idea maybe is no
longer relevant
well when I was going to school it was
like these Classics from I believe it
was um
I forget the name of the schools like
Johns Hopkins they had a list of all the
great Classics I come from a Humanities
background
and so there were books that I rather
sort of the canon in there that were
kind of Elemental
um but you know
so right now we're in a period of time
where science technology is dominating
our our schools Etc our way of thinking
and the humanities have kind of faded in
are actually being kind of closed off in
many universities people aren't
interested in them anymore but I think
it's very important to be able to ground
yourself in our history in our culture
in our civilization and some of these
Classics I think are still extremely
relevant and very very important to read
uh the reason is is it's not just
important what you read but it's
important how you read right so my
background in Classics because I studied
ancient Greek and Latin which is
probably the most irrelevant subject you
could study in University but I think
helped me very very much my ability to
organize my thoughts and organize
material
so a lot of these books they kind of
train you how to think how to interpret
how to read subtext how to get inside of
a book and take it apart and see what
somebody's really saying the the ideas
behind the ideas
etc etc I find that's a lot of that is
missing nowadays and people's thinking
is Getting Thinner and thinner and
thinner or they're not really analyzing
they're not going into any kind of depth
on the subject because they're so
distracted and they're going from
subject to subject to subject they're
scrolling
etc etc etc when you read a dense text
like I had to read like thucydides
history the Peloponnesian War it makes
you focus on on just one paragraph what
is he trying to say there what's the
meaning behind it it gives your brain
focus and discipline right so I think
reading going back to some of that is
extremely important even here in the
21st century and I I don't regret it all
studying perhaps the as I said
the most irrelevant subject of all
because I think it gave me a discipline
of mine that I would not have had
elsewhere but that said I think it's
important to have a wide-ranging
interest I like to read a lot about
science for instance I don't have a
science background but I'm reading a lot
of that for the books that I'm currently
writing and it kind of opens my mind up
to different ways of thinking it kind of
has a different logic to it than
literature or biography or history has
every kind of subject has its own logic
its own way of thinking it's some way of
exploring reality and the more you open
yourself up to these various different
ways of looking at the world you enrich
your mind but you also not just in the
content but in how you think so bringing
a kind of scientific mentality to my
material has been very important for my
thought processes
so I would I would throw a wide net out
there and read in many different
disciplines but kind of ground yourself
in a way of analyzing information
instead of digest digesting information
having being able to be critical and
analyzing I think is very important
along those lines in the books that you
write there is such a broad range of
both sorts of folks that you write about
and subject matter that you've read
about and you draw connections and
parallels between different eras in
history as well as between different
disciplines in all of that is there
anything that seems particularly
different about the current time that
we're living through that seems to be an
outlier based on the patterns and
connections that you've studied so
deeply in preparing all of the books
that you've written when you consume so
much material in history it kind of
changes how you think
and so a lot of people nowadays who
don't read a lot of history quite
frankly have this idea that everything
that's going on now is new and different
and modern it's never happened before
there's the old cliche in in financial
bubbles that this time it's different
you know like in 2008 with the new way
of doing a real estate equities that are
This Time It's Different you know with
AI This Time It's Different it's never
different it's the same patterns
repeating over and over and over again
throughout history I'm reading a book
right now about 12th century France I'm
writing about a couple of characters in
that period
it is incredibly modern the ideas the
ways people are thinking about love
about philosophy about ancient history
they're like characters that I see right
now in here in Los Angeles there's
hipsters there's guys with long hair
there's people discussing love and
freedom Etc so it's like they're like
hippies but wow this is this is
incredibly similar to our times we have
this illusion that things are different
the only thing that's different is
things get more intense so what social
media has done is it's taken qualities
that are inherent in human nature that
have existed for five thousand ten
thousand per hundred thousand years lack
of propensity for Envy our need to
constantly compare ourselves like our
self-absorption
like our aggressive impulses and it
simply gives them a way to accentuate
them it gives them like a megaphone for
instance so our our kind of
passive aggressive tendencies or our
hostility on on the internet and social
media it's like it's just exacerbated so
it's not like things are just not like
we've rewired ourselves it's not like
we've become different people
social media is having an effect on our
brains it's changing certain things it's
making things worse it's taking
qualities that we already have and
making them more and more extreme but
we're the same animal that existed in
ancient Greece in ancient Egypt Etc it's
just that we have tools now that we're
not really capable of handling in a
rational way our minds were developed
for a certain way of life that's
completely different than the 21st
century so we have these tools that are
so powerful but our minds aren't really
adapted aren't really made for being
able to handle them on a very realistic
way but I don't think the more I read
about history the more I have the sense
that human life civilizations and
cultures go in these cycles that just
keep repeating over and over and over
again so along those lines since you
brought up social media a couple of
different things
um in his two books amusing ourselves to
death and technopoly Which predated
social media Neil postman has an
analysis which if applied to social
media or a critique would be the
question of whether social media is a
net good is a less important question
than how can we maximize the good and
try to limit the bad Cal Newport on his
podcast not long ago had a piece about
the effect of what he calls unrestricted
social media use for young kids
particularly girls but both boys and
girls and he asserted that if the early
data ends up being what it appears to be
in something like 10 years the idea of
giving kids unrestricted access to
social media would be sort of like
giving kids cigarettes that it would be
like wow how did we ever not realize
that that was a really bad idea so sort
of a two-part question how interesting
do you think the question is of is
social media a net good and two what is
your sense of how the relationship to
social media might change as the as it
matures and we know more about its
impacts
well you know things that technology and
things that we create aren't necessarily
a net good or a net evil they're just
simply instruments that we can use that
are at our disposal that can help us you
know so I remember in the early days of
the internet as a writer
the incredible power that it gave me for
researching giving me access to
documents to academic things to books
that I couldn't normally never get or
find it was amazing so it can be an
extremely valuable tool for gathering
information for finding things out you
have a simple question about how to fix
something in your house three seconds
later you have it it's also an amazing
tool for connection for communication
where I can communicate to people who
have similar interests like I do around
the world it can be fascinating it could
be a wonderful tool
but it isn't like that it's turned into
something rather dark and rather ugly
and it's kind of decaying our minds like
too much sugar would on our teeth and
the reason is and I said it in my book
the laws of human nature is that this is
what human nature is we create something
and we slowly slowly kind of degrade
more more and more down to the lowest
common denominator it happened with
television and people are going wow
television we're going to be able to use
it now to educate our children they're
going to be educated on this incredibly
new level people were that naive in the
40s and 50s and then slowly would go oh
no it's not like that at all
so it's not the instrument itself that's
potentially good or bad it's our minds
it's how we use them how we bring human
nature how we have no discipline how we
just simply use things without thinking
about them
so the other thing that happens is
something like the internet becomes a
tool for making money instead of for
information for connecting for
communicating and how do we control that
we can't really control that because we
live in a capitalistic society and
that's the nature of these things but we
create these tools and we don't ever
think about how they're going to be
applied or the negative consequences for
them until it's almost too late and so
when I read now about Ai and all the
people throwing their arms up about oh
how dangerous it is even Sam Altman
who's the person developing this is
warning us about the dangers of it I
think it's rather ridiculous and absurd
for these people to be doing that
they're the ones creating it they're the
ones thrusting it upon us why aren't
they thinking about that before they
create it
why isn't someone like Steve Jobs
Imagining the incredible deleterious
effects that an iPhone could have on our
brains it's like it to me it all comes
back to human nature if we think about
the fact that we are very short-sighted
that we tend to be locked in the present
we don't have the Instinct of thinking
ahead and going what are the
consequences for this particular action
for this particular technology we're
going to be falling again and again and
again and again into this trap so I
think one thing that could happen as far
as dance the second part of your
question is that there is something in
us that is that is very real that they
cannot endure so much of this virtuality
in our lives we know that we're ruining
our brains we know that it's making it
distract distracting us to death to
quote Neil Postman that it's having a a
net negative effect on our ability to
focus
and my hope is that people who are
younger who are in their early 20s gen Z
Etc they start rebelling against this
like when I my age I was rebelling
against the world of my parents and sort
of the rigid and conventionality of it
that people go we want something more
real we don't like this relationship
that's that it's creating of of so that
we're
less and less social and we're more and
more virtual and there's a real
rebellion and people realize this is
what matters these are our priorities
but until we have a sense of what our
values are of what's important and to me
what is important is that we're a social
animal and that we're able to interact
with people on a deep and a profound
level that were human that were animal
that creates and builds things in order
to build things you have to master a
subject you have to understand it deeply
you have to be able to be patient and
disciplined these are things that I find
as high high ALT Mega values meta values
that we must have discipline Mastery
social interaction creativity and if you
have that kind of scale of values then
when you create something new and you
create something like social media and
you go well how does that help us in in
these things is this going to have a
negative effect but if you live in a
time where there are no more values
whereas kind of nihilism where there's
no sort of there's nothing kind of
grounding us of what's matter what
matters are important nothing will ever
change we'll never get a grasp of how to
use these things properly
we've been speaking with author Robert
Greene we'll be linking to a number of
his books uh Robert really appreciate
your time I know you're busy and your
your time and insights are very much
appreciated
thank you David thank you very much for
having me
follow us on social media interact with
the David packman show Community see
exclusive content See when we're taking
calls live and stay up to date on other
Big Show announcements WE Post daily
find us on Reddit Twitter Instagram
Facebook Discord and tick tock
all right uh politics doesn't have to be
entertaining it doesn't have to be
entertaining in the way that a TV show
or a movie has to be entertaining in
fact it's a problem that in many ways
our politics in the United States has
become one of the sideshow like an
action movie or whatever the case may be
rather than serious policy discussions
at the same time there's a difference
between entertainment and being a
completely
uninspiring and a pedantic uh bore in
the context of explaining to people what
you're going to do for them that would
say hey I think I'm going to vote for
you so when I'm going to play some clips
now for you of Ron desantis's speech
yesterday in Iowa and tell you that he
seemed to be trying to bore the crowd to
death it's not that I mean DeSantis
needs to be doing the insults that Trump
has become known for or the nicknaming
or any of that that's not what I'm
saying what I am saying is that he is
boring the crowd to death with
meaningless slogans and bullet points
that even he doesn't understand and
certainly don't connect to any important
policy that would help people here is
DeSantis for example talking about the
debt deal that is being worked on and it
seems that that has been reached they
now have a debt deal which they're
acting like is going to change things we
were careening towards bankruptcy before
this debt deal and the country is still
careening towards bankruptcy after this
debt deal uh we need big reform to be
able to get our nation back on fiscal uh
solid fiscal ground what reform how does
that relate specifically to the economic
situations of the people in the crowd
the problem with this sort of speech is
that not only is it retreading the same
tired lines that Republicans have tried
for a while it's been years since this
sort of republicanism was even at the
center of the Republican party and this
is not in any way connecting with the
average voter about what the sandis is
going to do then DeSantis just shifts to
woke and he talks about competing in the
woke Olympics he just can't get away
from talking about woke woke woke you
should not have to compete in the woke
Olympics just to qualify for employment
or to get into a college Merit must
Trump identity politics
this is essentially his campaign and it
couldn't be I mean he it couldn't be
less inspiring thank you for being here
today today we'll talk about how the
history of the paper clip has completely
gone woke at this point in time you know
paper clips are these small metal
devices they used to hold sheets of
paper together but now they represent
woke ideology and some people even bend
them into LGBT shapes I saw a paper clip
painted in the pride flag colors and
we're not going to do that in Florida
and if I'm president we're not doing
that anywhere okay they're gonna paper
you realize teachers who want to talk
about gender affirming care are using
colored paper clips we're not going to
allow it in Florida and we're gonna make
the entire country floor it's it's
meaningless stuff it just it doesn't do
anything it doesn't connect with anyone
here's one more clip of DeSantis talking
about a faucian dystopia under covid in
Florida we made the choice to choose
facts over fear we chose education over
indoctrination right and we chose to
stand for Law and Order over rioting and
disorder sure we held the line when
Freedom itself hung in the balance I was
not going to let the State of Florida
descend into some type of faucian
dystopia where people's freedoms were
curtailed and their livelihoods were
destroyed no we stood up for people's
rights we protected people's jobs and
small businesses and guaranteed like
your Governor did that kids had a right
to be in school and get an education in
person five days a week in short Florida
we chose Freedom over faucism and we are
better off for having done that it seems
like these speeches were written by some
kind of poor like by chat GPT one you
know it's not even like the stuff that
three or four can write for them and it
just does not have winner written
anywhere all over it by the way for all
of his bragging about covid Florida with
the 10th highest per capita coveted
death rate 10th highest per per capita
covet death rate so not exactly
something to brag about Donald Trump is
now Furious that Ron DeSantis stole one
of his lines but the truth is that Trump
stole the line from Reagan they're just
stealing the same stuff from each other
back and forth okay talking points memo
article Trump attacked DeSantis for
blatantly plagiarizing a speech line
that Trump actually took from Reagan
Trump actually took from Reagan the line
is the Great American comeback so team
Trump published this video of trump
using the line in 2020 and then DeSantis
using it now meaning to prove that
DeSantis stole it from Trump three years
ago we launched the Great American
comeback right tonight I stand before
you to share the incredible results
I'm Ron DeSantis and I'm running for
president to lead our Great American
comeback
so this is like the perfect microcosm of
what I expect the 2024 Republican
primary to be Trump attacked DeSantis
for stealing the phrase great American
comeback in reality Trump took the term
from Ronald Reagan Trump didn't invent
it by the way he also didn't accomplish
the Great American comeback but that's a
different thing if you do a Lexus Nexus
search for that term you have hundreds
of pages of results okay that the phrase
great American comeback has been used in
speeches for so long but you go back to
Reagan's State of the Union speech in I
believe it's 86 and there it was that
the uh in that particular speech Reagan
bragged about 37 straight months of
economic growth and falling interest
rates and he said it's because of
conservative values and he talked about
the Great American comeback so Trump
didn't invent it if you want to argue
that anybody has like a claim to these
phrases it would be Reagan also
important Trump didn't make up make
America great again Reagan used a
slightly different version of it back in
1980 where he said let's make America
great again let's make America great
again so my view is these are not such
unique phrases
that anybody really holds a right or or
not obviously it's not a legal right but
even sort of like a moral right to them
these are very general phrases in many
ways but to the extent that the idea is
that these are unique messages from
Republican candidates they're not and
Trump yelling at someone for stealing
something from him that he already stole
from someone else is uh pretty damn
funny I expect this to be exactly the
type of issue that these Republicans
argue about during the uh during this
campaign now one other just like kind of
funny thing you might have noticed that
in that ad Ron DeSantis pronounced his
name d santis this is like a kind of
funny thing
run DeSantis in older videos used to
pronounce his last name d santis and
then more recently while he's been
Governor it's been DeSantis and then in
that video he went back to DeSantis and
it's all kind of weird Trump posted
about this himself to his platform truth
social truth Central where he put have
you heard that Rob de sanctimonious
wants to change his name again he's
demanding that people call him DeSantis
rather than DeSantis actually I like Deb
better a nicer flow so I'm happy he's
changing it he gets very upset when
people including reporters don't
pronounce it correctly therefore he
shouldn't mind de sanctimonious this is
going to be the dumbest but possibly the
most corrosive Republican primary I will
have ever covered that's that's what I'm
expecting and that's what I'm preparing
for we have a voicemail number that
number is
2192 David P I've been talking about in
the midst of the Chick-fil-A Fiasco I've
never been to a Chick-fil-A and I said
maybe I'll go to one this weekend when
I'm going to be out in Long Island they
have a bunch of Chick-fil-As there but
when I looked at like their breaded sit
chicken sandwich the ingredients looked
so toxic that maybe I'd go with like the
grilled and a bunch of people wrote to
me and here's a voicemail saying David
don't get don't get that that's not the
right item to get
Steven the town from Jersey I hear
you're thinking of going to Chick-fil-A
yeah and you say you want to get the
grilled chicken David no like
restaurants have certain items on their
menu just for people like you like when
you go to a steakhouse they have salads
but the salads aren't any good it's just
for people that are in the group that
don't that don't eat meat or don't want
to stake but the salad's no good just
like you go to a seafood restaurant like
they have meatballs on the menu but you
don't get meatballs at a seafood place
this is on the menu for people that
don't like seafood true because like why
even a seafood place so don't go to
Chick-fil-A and get the grilled chicken
David you have to get the Chick-fil-A
original uh chicken sandwich I recommend
no pickles because they're these cheap
little they're they're not well other
people said definitely get the pickles a
real quality pickles so
um you can get no pickles add lettuce
and tomato
um and you gotta get the waffle fries
David because waffle fries have more
surface area
um so really all right I get the point
listen I I Pro I tend to agree like I
get the the sandwich Chick-fil-A is
known for is the breaded chicken
sandwich the thing about it is you look
at I just was cruising the website you
look at the ingredients it's like uh rib
meat injected with water
I I don't even really know what part of
the chicken the rib meat is I had to
look it up and it's like some connective
tissue between something and it I it's
not even a part of the chicken I was
familiar with it sounds really toxic it
really does but I do agree that
if I'm gonna do the Chick-fil-A thing I
should probably just get the classic the
classic sandwich so I don't know if
it'll end up happening I will report
back if it does and we'll kind of go
from there on today's bonus show we will
talk about Ken Paxton the Attorney
General of Texas being impeached we will
talk about how in Minnesota cannabis
users can't own firearms despite a new
law and we will talk about the two-year
prison sentence given to the woman who
threatened Nancy Pelosi with hanging
during the Trump riots all of those
stories and more on today's bonus show
don't miss the bonus show sign up at
joinpakman.com it will be a fantastic
day for everyone otherwise we'll see you
back here tomorrow on the Friday show
foreign